[Musique]
donc le public va nous suivre dans notre
parcours et en même temps découvrir le
lazaret pour ceux qui sont jamais venus
et pour ceux qui sont déjà venus au
lazaret découvrir les recoins les
endroits où va jamais et même rester un
peu plus longtemps dans les endroits où
on reste peu de temps comme le sim et
yappa raisin entre découverte et
parcours initiatique didier beauty ham a
évolué pour la représentation de son
projet elle hasard sur une scène unique
le site historique du lazaret de la
grande chaloupe à travers la danse le
théâtre et la scénographie le jeune
chorégraphe de 30 ans veut raconter la
vie des hommes et des femmes qui sont
passés par le lazaret berceau du peuple
mans de la réunion on parle d'un homme
qui est seul nom qui recherche sa
dignité
on parle d'enfance avec toute
l'innocence que peut avoir
voilà les enfants les adolescents sur la
vie on parle de d'espoir
on parle de rêve et voilà c'est tout ses
émotions que j'ai envie de dégager dans
mon spectacle un spectacle vivant
partager avec une vingtaine de jeunes
issus de la section danse du collège
bourbon
une représentation qui aura demandé
plusieurs mois de préparation avec la
danse m'a appris à s'amuser
après gérer les émotions le stress
sa joie se concentrer sur ça aussi et
avec la danse on est parti loin parce
que ça nous avait pas nous ça nous a
aidé à vivre en tant qu'artiste la
profondeur de nos sites patrimoniaux et
de pouvoir en même temps le transmettre
à nos jeunes mieux connaître son
histoire pour mieux se lancer dans le
futur c'est important
le spectacle el azhar est
l'aboutissement d'une résidence
d'artiste patrimoine et création de six
mois une action culturelle portée par la
collectivité de la réunion afin de
valoriser la création artistique qui
fait écho aux sites culturels
départementaux
[Musique]